[Musique]
chaque jour je me demande qu'est-ce que
je peux faire pour glenview
c'est pour ça que j'ai créé le club de
course à pied les cours d'espagnol au
foyer municipal de la brigade de
voisinage
[Musique]
mais ce court moment de brise âge de
glace de notre prière et les emmerdeurs
mais ce serait pas plus marrant de
vraiment brisé la glace en petits class
on y traite du whisky par dessus il ya
quelques années j'ai voulu devenir
membre des services de la police de
glendale où vous êtes un fou dangereux
j'ai pas senti la taille basse je me
fais un scénario dans ma tête une femme
au foyer sexy l'asiatique tout cela soir
appelons la brigade de voisinage et là
elle me laisse rien
j'aimerais bien aussi que ça m'arrive à
moi
[Musique]
allons voir ce que c'est c'est quoi ça
hé les gars j'ai trouvé un truc
[Musique]
et une invasion extraterrestre qui se
prépare quelle est sa police s'occuper
de sa chacune de ces personnes est
peut-être un alien
je vous présente son corps
donc la question qui fait qu'ils ont des
axones jouer impressionner mes potes je
voulais jouer les gros bras
je t'aime tu habitais des aliens des
défauts qu'est ce qu'ils aperçoivent on
regarde son visa regarde mon visage
regardons visage et écoute moi regarde
le écoute mon regard bleu mais comprends
moi bien regarde nous tous les données
sans nous comprendre écoute mes paroles
et en tant son visage
personnes touchent aussi cool tant qu'on
n'a pas découvert que ces gains
la vache mais ce truc est incroyable
qui veut poser avec l'homme les a
et même dans la peau